during its remarkably consistent and
lengthy run It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia has brought viewers the
dark and hilarious Adventures of the
gang who never learned the typical
sitcom lessons as they amusingly make
the world a worse place it's an intimate
DIY affair which makes for a very loose
set prone to improvisation with that in
mind here are some of the funniest
bloopers ever captured during the
filming of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia in season 10 the gang
undertook one of its most notorious
activities to date attempting to match
Hall of Famer Wade Boggs supposed off
the field record according to lore Boggs
once drank 70 beers during a
cross-country flight only D and Charlie
make it all the way to 70 by the time
their plane lands in Los Angeles but not
without some consequences it turns out
that drinking that much beer is going to
make even the heaviest drinker a little
gassy that is disgusting me to to to to
[Laughter]
in this scene to long-running plot
threads converge the first Dennis is
most likely a psychopath and second the
gang is frequently dismissive of Dee the
most reasonable person in their midst
Dennis and Dee are twins and yet nobody
yells at Dee with as much ferocity and
venom as Dennis here he rants about as
darkly as he's ever ranted so offended
by some minor slight I will dice you
into a tiny million little pieces I will
shove you into a box I will shove you
into a box and I'll put that box into
the freezer the Paddy's Pub crew has
tried a lot of get-rich-quick schemes
but none are as enduring as fight milk
Charlie and Mac concocted this alcoholic
dairy based protein drink for bodyguards
by bodyguards according to Charlie it
also oddly gives consumers the strength
of a crow Mac and Charlie tried to
attract interest in fight milk the way
the gang usually promotes a product with
a terrible homemade commercial these
outtakes are from that ill-fated shoot
what up
do you have good ideas y5o in the
seventh season Mac puts on a large
amount of weight forever obsessed with
physical fitness he proclaims that he's
cultivating mass conflating adding
flabby pounds to his body with getting
muscular as a result he spends a lot of
his time eating junk food particularly
in his downtime like when he and Charlie
are hanging out in the van during a
stakeout mission Charlie just wants to
snag one chip one of Sony's most popular
recurring characters is rickety cricket
a former high school classmate of the
gang who went on to become a priest
before hitting a downward spiral of
homelessness drug addiction and
disfigurement this blooper comes from a
scene in which cricket eats lemons for
sustenance dennis has proven himself to
be a violent reckless person with a deep
animosity for anything he perceives to
be below his station in life in this
fourth season clip he and Charlie walk
into a pretty rundown home Dennis
immediately shows disdain by
sarcastically referring to the place as
charming and quaint then to emphasize
his verbal eye rolling he picks up a
vase and throws it Mac was raised almost
entirely by his silent chain-smoking
mother as his father Luther spent Mac's
whole life in prison
Mac understandably has some daddy issues
to work through and in a season 2
episode he tries to connect with Luthor
by visiting him in the big house when
Mac offers to do with every can to win
his dad's love he asks Mac and Charlie
to smuggle heroin into the prison for
him Mac tries to use the favor as a
bargaining chip while Charlie gets a
little over-enthusiastic
if you could just give us a little
advice on how to handle the situation I
promise we will come back
our butts below like a Christmas
stocking somehow someway Charlie gets a
date in one fifth season episode so his
friends provide lots of advice for the
big night for one they specifically tell
him to not eat any cheese but Charlie
can't help but eat cheese when he's
nervous and well being on a date makes
him nervous Mac and Dennis find a
workaround telling Charlie just not to
breathe in the direction of his
companion so instead he gives them a
whiff of his tremendously stinky cheese
breath
[Music]